oi oi
olá eu sou produtora de leite aqui de
carambeí tem 19 anos já na atividade mas
encontrei muitos desafios e eu queria
mostrar um pouquinho para vocês da minha
experiência né quando meu esposo tocava
atividade sempre tocou já é do isso de
família né já era do dos avós dele e eu
era uma simples dona de casa né não me
envolvi a atividade era somente ele que
trabalhava na área do leite porém eu
gostava dos animais mas não tinha assim
participação diz assim ah eu sei tirar
leite eu sei fazer trata não sabia fazer
nada disso né a gente sempre te via só
de salto toda arrumadinha o que que você
entenda de leite aí eu falei assim bom
deleita não entendo nada mas o principal
eu tenho que é vontade de te tocar
eu não tenho preguiça né todo mundo riu
de mim né aquele momento mas foi aí que
eu insisti e eles falaram a gente vai te
dar essa oportunidade então mas se você
não tiver nenhum tipo de resultado em
três meses a gente para com atividades e
quando eu decidi que eu queria tocar o
que me levou a tocar a propriedade uma
propriedade bastante endividada foi
quando minha filha saiu do colégio
particular que ela fazia aula de alemão
fazer aula de inglês fazer a natação
estudava num bom colégio e aí eu decidi
quando eu cheguei no colégio para pegar
ela na hora do almoço ela chorando
bastante sendo bastante rejeitada pelos
coleguinhas aqui não é teu lugar
se você vende colégio de rico era o que
eles falavam colégio de holandês e aqui
no público não era lugar e foi ali que
decidiu falei eu tenho que fazer alguma
coisa para mim colocar minha filha de
volta no colégio particular essa é a
minha meta colocar minha filha no
colégio particular fazer ela voltar a
ter aquelas pelas mordomias que ela dia
no mordomias mas aquelas fazer as mesmas
atividades que ela fazia que eram que
ela gostava de fazer quando eu liguei
para minha mãe fala aí mãe a partir de
hoje eu vou tá tocando a atividade em
casa da leiteria a minha mãe de cara
falou assim eu não criei filha para
andar cheia de merda de vaca ela gosta
hoje da minha atividade tem o maior
orgulho de mim mas porém ela não gosta
que eu esteja envolvido no negócio
trabalhando porque hoje eu faço tudo na
propriedade né
bom e foi um grande desafio para mim
desde o início né meu primeiro dia de
trabalho quando eu cheguei nós temos um
único funcionário e o meu esposo já
tinha deixado muito claro para mim não
conta comigo para nada que se trata com
a atividade leiteira né já tinha deixado
muito claro e o meu primeiro dia de
trabalho nem uma bota de borracha ainda
tinha para estar no meio dos animais
cheguei já tinha estudado tinha lido
muito sobre manejo de animais tudo que
era relacionada a leitaria pecuária eu
sempre tava envolvido além do revista
alguma coisa tava procurando informações
procurando palestras tudo que tava
envolvido eu sempre buscava
bom então meu primeiro dia do trabalho
eu cheguei falei para o único
funcionário que nós tínhamos né a partir
de hoje tudo que o senhor for tocar
tratar relacionada à leite o senhor vai
tratar comigo de cara o único
funcionário nosso falou eu mudo tudo que
você quiser que mude mas eu não recebo a
ordem de mulher de cara já tá legal se
você não recebe ordens mulher você não
trabalha mais para mim tu tá demitido e
como que eu ia chegar e falar para o meu
esposo que eu tinha admitido nosso único
funcionário só não sabia nem tirar leite
não sabia fazer trata não sabia fazer
nada daquela da atividade né então foi
um desafio muito grande e logo depois de
contratar um novo funcionário e esse
funcionário não teve problema nenhum e
me ensinar e aí ele falou assim ter
certeza que eu vou aprender muito com
você mal ele sabia que eu sabia pegar um
garfo para fazer o trato né
bom então corri atrás de bem-estar
animal palestras foi um grande
aprendizado até hoje tudo que eu vivi
jamais imaginava nem sonhava que eu ia
chegar tão longe contra isso nunca tive
vergonha chegava nas palestras onde o
pessoal todo chegava para para o jantar
né e eu ficava enrolando todo mundo
fazer aquelas perguntas mais bobas que
todo mundo sabia mas para mim aquilo era
novidade né então nunca tive vergonha de
perguntar aquelas perguntas mais bobas
que tinha
e hoje eu faço tudo que vocês imaginarem
na propriedade dirige o trator faça o
casco tiro leite tudo que um funcionário
faz eu faço hoje na propriedade fazer o
chip dos bezerrinhos faço tudo um
pouquinho meu dia a dia é um dia corrido
os dias que eu tiro folga começa 4 e 6
da manhã vou até 6 horas da tarde são
dias puxado mas porém muito positivos e
eu sou muito realizada hoje fazendo o
que eu faço quando eu iniciei a gente
tinha uma sala de ordenha muito precária
logo depois eu coloquei coloquei metas
na minha vida né e tantos anos 13 anos
eu quero construir isso e isso isso isso
construir sala de ordenha
o barracão novo que a gente tinha lugar
lugares para 25 animais hoje eu tenho
lugar para 140 animais no barracão tem
hoje trabalho com qualidade de leite tem
uma qualidade excelente no leite
o e consequentemente isso me leva a
ganhar uma bonificação a mais que quanto
um produtor tá ganhando umas 50 aí eu
pego um e setenta então é gratificante
para mim eu gosto de trabalhar muito em
cima da qualidade do leite bem-estar
animal aumentei meu barracão hoje tem a
140 lugares quero chegar 200 eu sonhava
com o dia que eu ia chegar a 50 animais
eu tava realizada porém quando eu chegar
a 50 passei para 70 passei para sem que
era um sonho hoje eu tenho 150 animais
em lactação e vou chegar a duzentos esse
é o meu projeto né
e hoje eu tenho total de 300 animais
quando eu iniciei eu tinha 60 animais
então vai evoluindo tudo muito rápido tá
indo super bem porém eu tô trabalhando
todos os dias junto com os funcionários
lá em casa a iohana hoje ela tem 15 anos
quando ela teve tinha oito anos a gente
descobriu um tumor no cérebro dela e a
gente vier fazer uma economia para gente
fazer uma reforma na nossa casa da nossa
casa era uma casinha de funcionário
quando a gente caso a gente entrou morar
numa casinha de funcionário e a gente
tinha um sonho que era casar também na
igreja né porém esse sonho e teve que
ser adiada para frente quando a gente
descobriu que ela teve tinha um tumor no
cérebro a gente fez a cirurgia foi 85
mil reais na cirurgia dela ela perdeu
setenta por cento da vista dela na
cirurgia porém está voltando graças a
deus né porque ela era novinha ainda
isso ajuda bastante na recuperação dela
hoje ela enxerga bem tá feliz tá indo
tudo bem é recebi o primeiro
em primeiro lugar a nível estadual de um
prémio de empreendedorismo na de 950 em
uma mulheres fica em primeiro lugar do
paraná o escutar nível nacional fiquei
em segundo lugar a nível nacional e mais
de 11 mil mulheres que foi o
reconhecimento muito grande para mim e
hoje eu colho bons frutos desse desse
prêmio né e o reconhecimento do meu
trabalho já fiz mais de 200 revistas já
participei dos vários programas de tv já
fui convidada para 2 reality porém não
aceitei porque eu tenho uma família tem
os filhos pequenininho eu não não
consegui mas quem sabe futuramente né
mas para mim hoje é muito gratificante
eu ver aquela menininha que não sabia
aquela moleca que eu sempre falo né que
andava de saltinho ou trocar aquele
salto pela aquela bota de borracha e sem
contar que a bota de borracha é muito
mais confortável
e eu tô super feliz hoje tô super
realizada e a condição financeira nossa
também mudou muito né a gente não
faturava nem 100 mil reais anual hoje eu
tenho faturamento de quase 2 milhões
então evoluiu muito e eu sei que eu
ainda posso falar muito mais ainda né eu
sou uma eterna sonhadora
e sonhos realizados né aí eu sempre falo
né aquele sonho do casamento e da casa
foi adiado mas ele saiu né eu sempre
digo sonha que você consegue essa foto
ali eu não fazendo parte de uma vaca foi
três horas antes do meu casamento a vaca
entrou em trabalho de parto e eu tinha
que fazer o parto a falta do meio a hora
do casal um pouquinho antes do casamento
e na outra foto foi de manhã logo 6
horas da manhã eu falo que aquela foi a
lua de mel né que tratando a vaca que
tava doente então esse sonho foi uma
grande realização da minha vida e eu
sempre falei para o meu esposo né que eu
queria casar e ele sempre empurrando
aquele sonho sempre empurrando até que
chegou a hora eu falei amor vamos casar
ele falou se você pagar o casamento eu
caso o meu usado mesmo né e eu paguei
toda a festa e falei para o seu pago a
festa a gente realizou esse sonho foi
hoje foi incrível a gente conseguir ter
as pessoas que a gente mais ama do lado
da gente naquele momento né os melhores
amigos então foi muito gratificante
um lugar eu sempre falo né que lugar de
mulher não é só na cozinha lugar de
mulher é aonde a mulher quiser porque
quando eu comecei todo mundo falava aqui
não é teu lugar falou porque que uma
mulher não pode tocar uma atividade
leiteira não pode fazer uma inseminação
né então eu não tem essa não pode quando
você quer quando você busca você
consegue fazer qualquer coisa eu falo
sonha alto porque os o céu é o limite né
e hoje eu tô bem realizada estou muito
feliz tenho uma família linda meu esposo
faz hoje o que realmente ele gosta que
ele faz toda a parte da agricultura e eu
faço toda a parte da leiteria eu faço a
parte administrativa de tudo né tanto da
minha parte quanto da parte dele e nós
dois formamos uma parceria muito bem
sucedidas tô bem realizada sei que fosse
muito mais longe ainda não imaginava que
eu
é muito né e hoje eu falo aqui a minha
história é um tapa na cara para que eles
que falaram para mim você não vai
conseguir aqui não é para lugar né então
é bueira bem alto e sempre falei desde
que eu iniciei a atividade do leite eu
nunca dormi sem dívida e nunca perdi o
sono por uma dívida né hoje eu falo
tenho financiamentos de 500 mil reais
mas consigo levar hoje tudo controlado
chega o dia de pagar tá o resultado tá
lá o dinheiro então a gente faz ela que
aquilo que a gente gosta a gente fazer
aquilo que a gente ama não tem por que
dar errado por ele você tem que se
dedicar com muito amor muito carinho e
muita sabedoria e fazer planejamentos
mas simplesmente você chegar e falar
assim ah eu quero fazer isso né você tem
que fazer o planejamento para você
conseguir chegar
o que é os desafios são aí e todos para
serem alcançados superados né para mim
foi um grande desafio mas eu tô muito
realizada obrigada
e aí